Donald Trump is having a tough week his
former campaign manager and campaign
chairman Paul Manafort is allegedly
going to be indicted he then threatened
genocide against North Korea at what
might have been the most internationally
embarrassing United Nations speech in
history and he has now praised a country
that does not exist when I heard that
Donald Trump would be lunching with
African leaders my ears perked up right
away because that is just ripe for
disaster and of course by disaster I
mean comedy gold and it was Donald Trump
praised the great work by the country of
Namibia which is of course not a country
here is Donald Trump in Guinea and
Nigeria you fought a horrifying Ebola
outbreak Gambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient and it was
not just once but it was at least twice
here's Donald Trump again talking about
the great country of nambia and I'm
greatly honored to host this lunch to be
joined by the leaders of Cote d'Ivoire
Ethiopia Ghana Guinea nambia Nigeria
Senegal Uganda and South Africa I guess
it's a portmanteau of Zambia and Namibia
right and the Gambia - and the Gambia
what's the Gambia another country the
Gambia yes I didn't know is the
interesting
well of course nambia is more
self-sufficient now they're doing huge
trade with LOM Wanda which is of course
a country from referenced in oh woe in
Mission Impossible there's a fake white
supremacist African country called la
Wanda reminds me of the Erdogan incident
remember when Donald Trump standing next
to Turkish president air Dhawan referred
to him as air doggone it is a great
pleasure to welcome president Erdogan
for his first visit to the White House
in years the American and Turkish
peoples have been friends and allies for
many many decades the cobb feffy trade
in nambia is amazing they've got some
really nice light roasts and they're
just doing a huge business beautiful
country beautiful beautiful country
things did not go well in general with
various UN delegations here's a picture
of the Zimbabwean delegation including
Robert Mugabe appearing to sleep through
Donald Trump's speech yesterday or the
day before where he referred to rocket
man and the total destruction of North
Korea if you're threatening genocide
against a country and Mugabe isn't
excited enough to stay awake for it
you know something weird is going on
that two fifths at minimum of the
Zimbabwean delegation sleeping through
the Donald Trump speech well I think the
gaffe at the luncheon yesterday is
actually pretty significant because I'm
sure all those African leaders went into
it understanding that Donald Trump
doesn't really care yeah and that's
verified if he doesn't even take the
time to learn the pronunciation of the
country well not only that but it's all
fun in games and AM bi it's all funny la
Wanda Donald Trump did say some horrible
things at that lunch with the African
leaders and Donald Trump sort of bragged
about how his friends are going to
Africa to get rich here's Donald Trump
talking about that and this really is a
serious thing take a look at this Africa
has tremendous business potential I have
so many friends going to your countries
trying to get rich I congratulate you
they're spending a lot of money that is
just horrible right Trump's bragging
about the raping and pillaging of the
resources of African countries and he
loves it right I mean for centuries
Africa's resources have been exploited
by Europeans and Americans Africa
victimized by the slave trade of Europe
and and the United States supporting the
US has supported dozens of authoritarian
and just brutal regimes in Africa and
the making of billions upon billions of
dollars from deals with dictatorships
and and the pillaging of Conflict
Minerals
it's a horrible reality we're in when
Donald Trump is sort of saying it's just
my friends are going to Africa and
they're just getting rich it's so
fantastic regulations at least his
buddies are getting rich though silver
lining well that is actually the only
connection to a real philosophy of
Donald Trump we can't really learn
anything about Donald Trump's philosophy
on free trade from what he says it's
just kind of what he heard and an idea
he came up with that he thought would do
well with voters he
real philosophy what Trump is really
impressed by is by his friends going to
Africa and figuring out a way to use the
resources of Africa to enrich themselves
greed self aggrandizement those are the
real philosophies that get Donald Trump
excited and that's a genuine moment this
is I don't it's so incredible because
it's such a great example Trump
genuinely seems like he understands his
friends are getting rich in Africa and
he really seems pleased by it that's the
window into the real Trump thrilled
about people getting rich off of others
resources and this story made me look
into pass mispronunciations by Donald
Trump yeah
some of my favorites 2 Corinthians which
we all know about course to be on si and
Beyonce and Tanzania another African
country maybe I've heard of it Tanzania
I am familiar with interestingly enough
the cob feffy trade has actually
destroyed Tanzania has really hurt
nambia but in Tanzania it hasn't worked
well